ちょうどあの感覚のことなんですけど
いいですか 僕はさっきの手を病あの画鋲を刺したらそこが痛いっていうのは
この心は単に最初は痛いっていうのだけを知っていて
その次にどこが痛いのかが理解するっていうか
場所をそこが痛いっていうのを理解するっていう風に
あの なってんのかなっていう風に思っているんですけど
ただ そういう風には普通はもう直接両方いつも感じてるから
あの まあその区別はしてないじゃないか
あの 実際 我々の普通の生活の中では
どこが痛いっていう風にもすぐ感じてるけど
実はそうじゃないんじゃないかなと思ってるんですけど
どうでしょう っていうのが
例えばですね まあいろんな瞑想の時もあるんですけど
あの足がない人が 足を手術で切っちゃった人が
ないはずの足が痛かったりすることがあったりするんですね
それはあまり適当かどうかはあれですが
例えば瞑想をしている時には
自分の手の位置っていうようなものが
その自分が普通感じている位置と違うっていうことを時々あるんですけど
あるいは痛い場所っていうのは
足が痛いんだったらここが痛いはずだというようなことがあるのに
違うところが痛かったりするっていうか
そういうことがありそうなので
心は今の痛いっていうのだけは最初に感じてるけど
どこが痛いとかっていうのは別の事象として認識してるのかなっていう
痛みは体は通さないとないものです
まあそんなのもただの妄想で推測することにまあ答えるのも疲れますけど
痛みっていうのは まあ体に何か物質触れると起こる感覚で
それが痛みとして心は認識するし
あるいは別な認識したりもするし
痛いか愉快か それは時その時
体が勝手 心が勝手に認識するものですけどね
事実はそれだけなんです
うーん 他何も言うことはないんです
私には 最初は痛みがあって
そちら行ってるのは最初は痛みがある
それから心は後からそこらに場所を一つ認定してあげるという話なんです
それは仏教じゃないんですけど
そういうふうに明確に言葉にするとね
なんで最初から痛みがあるんですかね
心にあるのは痛みじゃないんです
心にあるのは別な感覚なんです
ドゥーマ・ナッサっていうと憂いなんです
心だけ感じる場合は憂いというものを感じるんです
痛みっていうのは感じないんです
心は 痛みっていうのは物質が触れる時
心は適当にするラベルだけ
だから同じく同じ感覚に時々気持ちいいと言ったりするし
時々痛いとも言ったりするし
だから心はその時その時好き勝手にあのラベルする
ラベルする時は好き勝手でもなくて
前後関係というか ちょっと前の関係も配慮して
じゃあこの場合は痛みにするそうと
この場合は気持ちいいにするそうと
いうふうに 苦か楽か 不苦不楽かっていう感覚にするんです
それはもうちょっと前の感覚に合わせるんですね
例えば強烈に痛みというものを認識している時は
例えば火傷してもう痛くて痛くてしょうがない
その時誰かが針を持ってきて体に刺す
刺してもわからないんですよ
何か触られたなと じゃあだけで終わっちゃうんです
なぜかというと もっと前の痛みっていうのは強烈ですから
今の感覚は まあこれは不苦不楽にしようということにするんです
前は随分気分良く穏やかにいた時は
誰かが針を刺して何するんですか？痛いんじゃないかと突然飛び上がっちゃうんです
では その人同じ針を刺す時はいつでも痛いというかというと
そう言わないんです だからこの苦と不苦不楽っていうのは
まあそうやって まあその時その時心はやってるラベルだけです
まあそういうことは瞑想する人々
まあ結構何人かがあそこら辺はよくわかっていろいろ言ってるでしょうね
だからまあ 苦で取るか
楽 不苦不楽で取るか もうまあ好き勝手ですよ
心は あるいは足がすごい強烈に痛くなっていたんだと
それでも心はどんどん瞑想してる場合に限りますけど
別なことに集中してしまっちゃったというと
足？足がどうなっていたんです？もう全然さっぱり忘れてるんです
あの痛みってのは だからまあ
もし足が痛くて大変なことだったら病気になるでしょうね
病気になりませんよ 痛みを忘れたんだからといって
だから痛いか気持ちいいかということは
まあそのちょっと前の流れとかね
いろんなものを見て それなりに適当なラベルをする
まあ針を刺す場合でも
ほんのちょっと気持ちいいと
もうちょっとやっぱり気持ちいいとか
もうちょっとでやっぱり痛いというでしょうね
だから同じ圧力でしょ
[無音]プロレスラーたちはね
もう快感感じてるんですよ
ぶん殴られるし もう叩ける
もうもうもう落とすでしょう
ドーンと あのリングの中でね
そこで上へ登って この膝でこうやって人の体にあの体重
体格で落ちるでしょうに
普段転がってきたって死ぬぐらいのあんな体格で強烈に
であれでやられた人は死にそうに苦しいんですよ
苦しいんだったら逃げるでしょ
逃げませんよ あれで快感感じてるんです
もう我々にやられちゃうとその場で死んじゃいますけど
あの連中はそれで快感感じてるんで
だからもう痛いか痛くないかそんな話じゃないし
先に心の痛みがあるということは仏教じゃないんですよ
だったら人間っていうのはずっと苦しんでるというか
痛くてたまらんでしょうね
それはないでしょう 痛みっていうのはどうせ体のことなんです
心には痛みがないんです
心にあるのは憂い 憂いと感覚には体は関係ないんです
憂い悲しみというかね
ドゥーマナッサという専門用語ですけど
もしかすると日本語では憂いとか悲しみとかだと思います
ドゥーマナッサの場合は別に体は関係ないんです
まあ例えばもう足の格好悪くて気分悪いと言えば
別に痛くはないんですけど
気持ち悪い それはドゥーマナッサ
憂いですね なんで俺の足が短いでしょうかと
かっこ悪いなと思う時は
別に足が短いんだからで痛いわけないでしょうね
何か不自由があるわけないでしょうに
何もない でもえらいコンプレックス感じている
それがもう純粋な心の感覚
足が短くてコンプレックス感じる人は憂いというものなんです
足が痛いと感じる場合は
必ずもう壁かどこかにぶつかってるんですね
それで痛みを感じる それには長い短いは関係ないんです
そこで階段でぶつかったんですけど
ある人はちょっと気持ちいいと言うかもしれませんし
ある人は痛くてたまらんと言うかもしれませんしね
痛みの評価はそんなもんです
足が手術して足切った人が足痛いっていうのは憂いを痛いと感じてるんですか？ 知らない
え？右足の先が痛いんだ痛いんだって言うんですけど
そうしたら右足の先ないんです
だからそんなのは誰かから誰かから聞いて聞いて済む
もう噂話みたいなものだから
もう実際に事実を知らない限りはね
そういう仏教的な判断はできない
たまたまそういうことを私も言うんだけど
そういうのはちょっとちらっと言うだけで
真剣なことじゃないんです
まあそれはまあどちらかというと妄想でしょうしね
頭の中でね まあ妄想 概念があって
だから妄想の中ではもう何でもあり得るんだからね
ですから まあ翼があるんだそうと妄想しちゃうと
実際に翼があるように感じるんですよ
ない足だけじゃないんです
そんなのはもう病気でしょうに
だからそれは俺どちらにするんですかね
具体的に言えば足がないんだから
翼もないんだからね まあ翼が重くて
今日はもう濡れちゃって
ちょっともう重いんだなとかね
翼あると思う人はそう思ったりする
足がないとでも痛いと思ったりする可能性はありますけど
そんなのは精神的な異常な人のケースだから
もう科学的な分析ではね
扱わないんです 稀な例外でしょうね
なんで例外ばっかしで普遍的な真理に使うのかと
役に立たないしね まあ実際にそういうデータも持ってる専門家にも話したことありますけどね
もう腹立たずだけで 私はでも何も反論できない
向こうは肩書持ってるんだから
ああそうですかと バカじゃないかと
ただ例外ばっかり出しちゃって
それで普遍的な論理を推敲して
あなたは何者かと ある人はもうもう大教授で医者で
大勢の人が来て話を聞いていたんですけど
私ももう聞いていたんで
私はえらい気分が悪いんで
本人も後で何かもうおかしいところでもありましたかと
個人的に私に結構ね いい何でもないんです
大丈夫です 他の人みんな感動してるんですけど
私はアホじゃないかと
こいつは たった一つの例外だけ出しちゃったりして
本人が研究してるんだから
それはもうデータがそれなりに意識的なんですけど
うん だから私に分かりません
例えば足が痛い いない人がない人がね
痛いという場合は それは
どういう痛みかと 売りにはならんでしょうね
売りじゃないね それ 場合でも
やっぱり俺っていうのはあくらかに精神的なことだからね
おそらく あの あの回路が動いているでしょ
だから神経はもう足を取っちゃうとそこから切ってますけど
そこまでやるでしょうね
だからこの足が痛い時
流れた同じ回路でもう流れている時々流れちゃうデータが
そうすると実際に痛みを感じる可能性あります
だから神経伝達したっていうことは
物質的に触れたっていうことだから
だから神経電気だけ流せることっていうのは触れなくたってもできるし
だからそういうちょっとした余計なことだとは思いますね
で 欲望ありますから やっぱり足がないっていうことは認めたくないし
だから脳のプログラムは新しくもうアップデートしていないんですね
足が取った途端 プログラムを新しくアップデートしないと
それはしていないでしょうし
だから古いプログラムで走ってます
なんかインドのインド系のアメリカ人の医者がそれを原子を斬るっていう療法をやるらしいんですね
だから切った足がない足をなんかこう頭の中でもう一度それを切り落とさせるという
そうするとなくなったっていう
そうしなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからこのプログラム
新しいプログラム入れ替えてあげないと
それが方法です  集中して
なんかこう 頭の中でガチャガチャ回ってる回路をデバッグするみたいな感じで止めてしまえば
根本的にそのややこしいイメージで切るとか
そういうことはしなくてもいいわけですね
そんなことで お前足がもう明日からないんだよと言っちゃえばそれだけのことなんですよ
それ単純なことを医者やらないんだからね
明日からお前に足がないんだからとかね
それやらないで妄想ばっかでガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ
例えばもう癌で何かそこら辺癌ですからね
じゃあ取りましょう 別に何のことない
それだけが単純でアプローチすると
瞬時にその心でもう取る前にプログラムできてるんです
で 本当のところはこの麻酔もいらなくなりますよ
本当にプログラム作っちゃうと
で もう明日からもうここら辺はもう摘出するんだから
もうないんだと 言うと
前からこの 2日とか 人が病院でいろいろ検査しなくちゃいけない
いかないでしょうにね
その間では別に なんかいろんな私も患者さんも見たんだから
で 見てみると やっぱりもう仏教の国ということもありますけど
みんな結構前 初めから前からも 1週間前からはもう心の準備ができてるんで
そこはもうその部位はもう自分にないということで
よく喋りますよ これがね
すごく苦しかったんだよとかね
先生がなんかすごいダメだと
もう命がないんだと言ってるんだからね
これまあもう明後日ですね
明後日取りますとかね
堂々と言うんですね だからその時もこの苦しみ
明後日までというと もうとっくにプログラムできてるんです
それで手術をというのは随分うまくいくんですよ
だって自分の国では 1 日もう何件もやっちゃいますから
医者は で たくさんの患者がいるでしょうに
もう信じられない あのスピードと
もう朝 9時ぐらいに始めたら
もう次の患者 次の患者
次の患者 もう交代でギシギシギシギシやっちゃうんです
だから看護婦さんやらそういうみんな大変です
もうもうちゃんと資料をこう重ねておいて
取り出して そこでまあ手術セットパーンと出しちゃって
それを終わった途端 ピシッとこれ片付いて
次のセット出す 次の患者が来る
それである日手術前の部屋で見たんですけど
麻酔かけてるともう寝ているんです
そのままで それで時間見たら看護婦さん来て
もう叩いてみて 名前呼んでみて
ちょっと見ると はいはい
次の人 じゃあこれ病院にやったけど
次の人 その間またあちらの中に入ってきて
あれやっても 何でしょうか
あれは なんかこの工場で機械
コンベアベルトで作業やるような感じなんです
でも確実性はこちらよりはいいんです
そんなに事故を起こしたなんとかっていうことは大体ない
でもうみんなもう諦めてるというかね
それで外へ出しちゃったら
本当に手術した医者っていうのは大体はみんな見に行かないんですよ
もう弟子たちやらいっぱいいるんだからね
まあそういう人々がやっぱり先生見た方がいいやと言ったら
もうその人は来るんです
でないとそちらで話し合って帰るんです
手術によって まあまあ
メインの医者がサインしなきゃできない場合もありますけど
大院が 私がいた時代ではそんな調子なんです
今はもっとひどいんですけどね
それで金払って こうプライベート病やってる病院に行っちゃうと
もう本当にものすごいややこしいんですよ
お金が無茶かかるだけだけではなくて
治す確率が少ないんですね
だって金持ち気分でしょうに
人の一生の財産かかりますよ
1つの手術に だから金持ちしか行けないし
行って まあおだてておだててもらって
もうくどいな あれとこれとね
それで結局欲ばっかしで諦めきれないんですね
だから私は見ていたんだから
やっぱりみんな手術待ってる人々はもうとっくにその部位は捨ててるんですよ
それでもう麻酔かけるの
私もちょっと体一部何かできがあって
それ取り出そうとしたところでずっと見たんです
とにかく で 自分ももう取る取って捨てるものだから
自分も別にもう諦めていたし
だから別に麻酔かけなくたって
私の場合は痛くないと思います
麻酔はまあ一応リストでかける予定でしたけども
医者に私は あんた何で来たんですか？私にそんなこと言ったって
これできたんだよ ああそう
まあこれはもう何もいらんよということで
ちょっとちょっとした注射だけでいいんじゃないかってことでね
すぐ瞬時に変えたんですよ
これ全部いりませんと
言って それ見て まあちょっと注射打って
ちょっとよしちょっと待ってと言って
外を出て タバコ吸っていたら
タバコ半分ぐらい吸って
また来てちっちっと切って
はい終わり もう 1 分以内
でも自分が気持ちを取っていたんだから
結構大きい何かを体から外へ出すっていうことは分かります
ああ 私の一部なくなる
その気持ち 何もないんです
なんか変なものを取り出されたという気持ちで
それでどれぐらいこれは左か右か私今忘れているんです
見ても痕もないんです
切った痕も そんなもんですよ
心でちゃんと もう脇に出たんですけど
今も覚えてないんで これ左でしたっけ右でしたっけと
結構苦しかったんですけど
前は でも普通の人だったら大変でしょうしね
これがもうチェックしてチェックして
もう顕微鏡でも細胞を調べて
またちょっと細胞が残っているんだぞとか
それでまた他のところにも移転しているんだぞとか
いろいろ大変です だから初めからまあまあこんなのはもうもう捨てるんだ
いらんものだと言っちゃったの
プログラムはもう我々ゴミ出す時同じことでしょうね
まあこれはゴミとポイ捨てる瞬間で
ああ やっぱりそれでもということないでしょうに
だからゴミに対するアプローチで生きていない
生きているならば結構楽なんです
だから足を捨てたのに
ああ もったいないと思っちゃうと
で そこをね 別に摘出するんだからということは
もうどうしても役に立たないという意味でしょうに
まあその とにかくこの物質的な体の神経回路のプログラムは未だに旧型で動いている
もう足がないんだから
足がないプログラムに入れ替えなくちゃいけない
それはやってないんだから
もうそこで旧型で動いていて
もしかすると痛く感じるでしょう
憂いじゃないね やっぱり
憂いっていうのは別なことで
もう本当に足がないんだからね
かっこ悪いし 走れないしね
去年もうマラソンにも行ったのにとか
それは憂いなんですね
今年のマラソンに車椅子であっさりかっこ悪いなとかね
私はすぐ最近まで元気ピンピンいたんではないかとかね
そんなことを思ったりするところは
もう足がないことはもう確かで
その悲しみはどうしようもない
それは憂いということで
憂いは痛みよりはひどいんですよ
ほとんど憂いというのはないから生まれるんだからどうしようもないんですよ
だからすごいたちが悪い
痛みはもうもう蚊に刺されて
昨日もあったんですけど
あちこち蚊に刺されてもう我慢できない
痛くて それでもう江川さんに行ったらなんかもうビワの葉っぱの喫茶ありますか？って
それは手足どこでも塗って
それよりはこぼしちゃったんですけど
まあそれで ああ もう治りましたと
簡単ですよ でも ああいうことはないなぁと
憂いになっちゃうとキリがないんですね
随分仲良くしていた人なのに
楽しかったのに死んじゃったなぁと憂いしちゃうと
もう影響的でない状態は
ある状態はすぐなくなりますからね
木の蚊に刺されてもう痛みというものあった状態だからね
あることはなくなります
それで気分爽快です ない状態で苦しむちゃうと永遠です
ない状態はそれで永遠だから
だから憂いっていうのはとても危ないんです
痛みは何のこともない
しかし 私たちは憂いよりは痛みの方がすごく気にするでしょう
それは現代人の病気なんです
スリランカの場合はかなりこの心理学的なところを結構使います
私はまあ 6歳か 7歳 まあその間かなと
この指が遊んでもう潰れちゃったんです
姉と遊んで 兄貴ですね
兄貴と遊んでいて で 小さい
まあ当時で小さかったんですですからね
で 全部この前の筋肉がちゃんとつぶれちゃって
で ぐちゃぐちゃになっちゃうんだけど
歯車にちょっと機械があって
その機械の歯車に入っちゃったんです
で 兄貴がすごく怖くなっちゃうんですけども
その人のせいではなくて
まあその人に回して はい後ろに
はい前に はい後ろとか言った私が悪いんだからね
向こうは私は遊んであげようと思ってやっただけのことで
で 指が入っちゃって 指が痛くなった
そのままもう泣いて母に見せたところでも
母がもうそれだけでも体が硬直しちゃったんですね
で それで母は仕事をやめちゃって
でもその時はまあ父親の出る場だからね
父親は何のことなくお風呂を巻いてもらって
もう運んで病院に運んで行ったんですね
母は行かなかったんです
そこでもうもう潰れちゃったんだから
もうもう全部切って捨てるしか方法ないんです
医者何考えたかわからないんですけど
麻酔かけなかったんですね
おそらく すごい体が小さかったんだから
もう昔でしょうし そんなにね
麻酔も発達してるわけでもないしね
で 今だったらほんのいろんな注射種類ありますけどね
いろいろ喋ることをこの医者が
もう でも人 2  3人が来たんです
来て 私を一応捕まってはいる
何やってるんだこの人と
で 医者えらく私を褒めまくるんですね
周りも全部賛成ですごく褒めまくるんです
褒めまくってて褒めてもらえて
もうこちらがすごくもうもうもうこれで心配して
もう指がやられちゃったんだからね
なんとかしてくれ その間にそのまま生でちりちり全部切っちゃったんです
肉がちゅっと切って捨てたらその場でちゅっ痛くなるんですけど
もうもう泣く暇がないんです
向こうはえらい色んなこと言ってるんだからね
ああ しかしすごいですね
羨ましいですね なんとかなんとか言うと
それに乗ってるんです
それで治療して 一応また父親がもうもう抱っこして
もうそれでくると まあ父親に甘えちゃうんだから
それから体中痛くなるんですね
やっぱりそれはもうやっぱりもう父親にも弱音を言いたいんだからね
心配してほしいということで
だからまあそんなもんで
別にもう切っちゃえばいいっていうぐらいのことで
時々本人こういうことで気づく前にもう瞬時に終わってる場合もあります
あの みんなこのぎっくり腰とか何とかいうこと
まあ我々もよくここら辺はやっちゃいますよ
この足とかね 手とかも遊んでるんだから
遊んでて何かにドーンと落ちたらここら辺こうなっちゃうと全部擦れちゃうでしょうね
並の痛さじゃないんです
で それでもうそういう知って誰かにこれ大変な
こう泣きながらで やっぱりこれなんかここら辺でしょうかねと言いながらカチンとやってるんですよ
もうもうこれから治療しますよという話にして
これ結構時間かかるんです
それでこちらがまあこれからでしょう
今調べてるだけやと思った途端
カチンってやって まあ終わりましたから
じゃあ帰ってちょうだいと
あの瞬間の痛みにはもう準備できてないんです
だからもううまくいくんですね
これは引っ張って元に戻さなくちゃいけないんだから
これからこれは引っ張って元に戻してあげますから
ちょっと痛いんだけどとか言っちゃうと
もう余計に痛いだけ 日本の病院に一回行って
何かこの胃の検査でも
これ胃を止まるために何か注射するでしょう
これはものすごく痛い
だけどこれ看護婦さんが一人で悩んでるんですね
すごく痛いんですけどとか
普通の注射っていうのは痛くはないんだからね
もうこの女の話聞いてもうるさいんだから
もう黙って聞いてないんです
もう確かにその薬は痛かったんですけど
もう話聞いてないんだから
私は だから余計に痛くさせようとするんですね
それは思考なんです だから本人がその薬は痛いということを知っている
そこで心配して もうずっと笑っていたんだから
私はね やっぱりまあ本人も笑わせていろんなことをやっていたんだから
なんかもう本当に申し訳ないという気分で
それで逆に迷惑なんですね
だからそんなことを普通の精神的な状態がね
弱い人に言うとね かなり痛いでしょうと思いますよ
みんな で まあ私もやってます
大体仏教の世界ではもう先にもう諦めるんですよ
もう終わり それは何もないことにするんだというそれでも脳のプログラムがもうすぐもう更新してるんです
問題というのは このプログラムを更新しないで
古いプログラムで新しい体を運用しようとしちゃうと
こたらぶっちゃうんです
うん まあそんなことで
これで話は終わります
アサリーランということなんだけど
ん？ シャリーランですね
シャリーラっていうのは体でカーヤと同じような意味
そうしますと チッタとカーヤ
ナーマとルーパ 仏教では別物だというふうに考えています
仏教では別物というふうに考えていますよね
ルーパと チッタとカーヤとか
ここであえて心に体がないっていう風に言ってるというのは強調されてるんですか？ まあ心の直訳を言うんだから
心にはルーパが入ってないんだよとね
あえて  あえてではなくて
そういうふうに言った方がいいんじゃないかと私は思いますけどね
またグハみたいなこの遠い昔のね
単語も使ってますから
やっぱりアサリーランということも言わないと
ちょっと補わなく 合わなくなっちゃうのはなぜかというと
バラモン人が魂はこれぐらいだと言っていたんだからね
そういうバックグラウンドがあって
魂は親指ぐらいで完璧な人間の形をとっていたんだと
こんなのとんでもないということで仏教が始まるんだからね
あるいはアサリーラのアサリーラのものであるといえば
ナーマのものであるという意味になりますしね
強引な文学的に文法的な解釈というとね
サリーラとアサリーラという風になっちゃうんですね
であんまり使わない単語ですけどね
私は注釈書を見ながらずっと整理整頓したからね
では どうもありがとうございます
乾杯